Kentucky confirmed they want to charge a
15 year old alleged shooter as an adult
he's accused of killing two fellow
students at school Preston Ryan cope and
Bailey Nicole holt Adriana Diaz is at
Marshall County High School in Benton
where she spoke with a student whose
friends were wounded in the attack
Adriana good morning good morning
students here just want answers
they say the 15 year old suspect who
were not naming because he's a minor was
in the band and was known as friendly
President Trump tweeted his condolences
to families yesterday and in this small
town they're holding on to cherished
memories of the two 15 year olds who
died in this tragedy I played baseball
with him for three or four years and
Jacob Landis says the locker room will
never be the same without Preston Ryan
cope he's an incredible kid I mean every
time you saw him he was small and he
walking down the hallway he never had
anything negative to say 15 year old
Bailey Nicole Holt died at the scene
her mother described her as a perfect
sweet soul and called the tragedy
unbearable for our family everybody just
froze and didn't know it's Jana
Keaton gamble says students were
socializing in the commons area of the
school when shots silenced the crowd
nobody knew it it was at first then you
saw the boy with the gun
some teachers were pulling kids into
rooms and then they were crawling up the
window windows of classrooms a full
classroom of kids call out a window just
trying to get get away from the school
Keaton tells us two of her friends were
injured one shot the other suffered a
concussion from being trampled during
the commotion
yesterday's students from Marshall
County High joined others from a nearby
school for a prayer service and vigil
gamble says the community will heal as a
family everybody is just so loving to
each other and they want to make sure
you're okay and be by your side there's
anything investigators haven't revealed
any information about a motive and the
shooter will appear in court is expected
to for the first time today he faces two
counts of murder and 12 counts of first
degree assault the school here remains
closed as students attend counseling
sessions it was supposed to be their
homecoming game tomorrow
Noora goodness Adriana thank you